cette condamnation correspondait d'abord
aux réquisitions du parquet donc elle
est conforme à ce que nous souhaitions
pour des faits qui sont graves
tout le temps on ne s'en prend jamais
aux forces de l'ordre mais qui dans ces
temps de crise particuliers prennent
encore plus de dons encore plus d'impact
les forces de l'ordre sont en difficulté
elles ont leurs propres inquiétudes
elles sont aussi en attente de
protection de la part de leur ministère
donc les comportements des citoyens
doivent être de nature à faciliter tout
ce qui est en train de s'appliquer c'est
à dire le confinement des dérogations et
des contrôles sur les possibles
dérogations
donc quand ces comportements là ne sont
pas au rendez vous de la part des
citoyens il est important que le
judiciaire et notamment le droit pénal
trouve à s'appliquer